hello welcome back to big mood
who we got here we got gina tiff nikki
and jess
they're regulars the usuals you know
hi it's your first time listening those
are our voices um
today we're doing something pretty
exciting new new things new things
everyone
if you follow us on instagram or if you
follow us on youtube if you subscribe to
our youtube channel
we posted that we would like some
assumptions that you have about us
and we're pretty transparent which is
which made it kind of difficult a lot of
you were like you guys
have said your whole lives like yeah
yeah i mean mostly not everything
yeah we keep some secrets we're allowed
to have some [ __ ] things to ourselves
an ounce of privacy yeah you can't sell
our whole [ __ ] booty holes you know
yeah
yeah just half a half of starfish just
like part of the
the pucker just a little part of the
pucker just the inner circle of the
pucker but not the whole house
did you guys just pluck your butthole
too no no how do you do that
i can only push out squeeze the
sphincter i think i have a
i have a a weak swing
when you do a kegel don't you also
squeeze your butthole i don't do okay
goals yeah
girl you should i know i'm doing it now
i should because i have a what's that
pelvic thing where you like
yeah i have a weak pelvic floor
accidentally yes when i laugh too hard
or when i like cough like when i had
bronchitis oh my god it was just like
soaked that's been happening to me
lately yeah i'll sneeze and a little pee
will come out and i'm like oh i'm
[ __ ] getting
dude i'm getting older dude i haven't
stopped
because you know i haven't had sex in
like a year i kind of like stopped
working my pelvic floor out and i like
stopped doing kegels and now my [ __ ]
shit's getting loose i'm [ __ ]
sneezing and pissing on myself like
dude i have the opposite problem and
this is a little tmi but
you know how like when we have our
periods and then like you know
like i'll wear a panty liner because i
usually i wear a tampon but like this
last one i didn't wear it
tampons hold on hold on but
i have the opposite problem because um
like my panty liner stays completely
clean
and cause it's like just holding it all
in until i sit on the toilet and it all
comes out
so i'm like my [ __ ] is a problem we'll
see the thing about
the urethra and the vagina hole are too
separate because the vagina hole it
feels like i'm a virgin every [ __ ]
time we have sex
but my pee hole i don't know like i
busted my mouth too hard and it's
it lets it all out all right well this
is getting way too
those weren't any people's assumptions
no yeah just to prove to you that we're
transparent yeah there we go
just to prove it we actually have um our
set daddy and i know he hates that term
but he is a dad now
yeah yeah george kimmel is the first
time we've seen him in over a year
yeah aka pink dick from tiger belly he
is on set
we're so happy to have him here we asked
our producers to pick
the assumptions so that we're surprised
so that we don't like get super biased
on what we're picking yes right but like
just
feed it to us go nuts what do you think
we should answer whoa
jess would be the first to throw a punch
in an argument then gina then tiff the
nicki yeah do you believe that nikki
wouldn't throw a punch i would never
throw a pose she would
hide in a corner and cry while
everyone's hurting each other it was so
funny then i guess that's accurate
because i thought i would be last
but we would be huddled up together but
i would i would throw a [ __ ] point
i could see you throwing a punch like
your
karen you know like i'll like call
management i'll complain about no girl
remember that that time when we went
bike riding in marina del rey
she almost went she almost got down let
that die and we almost got down
what happened tips spilling your secrets
what happened
okay what happened okay this is not
my normal behavior but we were marina
del rey
marina we were running bikes at miranda
right off the side freeway so white it's
just
no i was with a bunch of asians i was
with david so and joe
and tiff and casey and like i don't
remember all who was there yeah
but anyways we were riding bikes in the
renaissance and then this [ __ ]
i was riding on the right side you know
bike path and this [ __ ] [ __ ] tries
to
like go around me i guess i was going
too slow for her fast ass
but she like clipped me and i did i fall
or it almost fell off you almost fell i
almost
i didn't wobble but then i kept that's
scary
but then so i just [ __ ] started
screaming what did i say i don't
remember i was just like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] she got so excited
she started fighting even fart like
faster to get away from me because she
was like not expecting my
[ __ ] white ass to be like [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
yeah like her inner demon came out where
i was like oh my god jess is about to be
definitely road rage i think i even i
don't know if i made this up in my head
but i
i feel like he joe even held you back
like i remember
on bikes
like you getting off your bike and then
joe being like no no no she's like
hanging in her bell aggressively
like that's how like g you came out oh
like that's how i end up remembering
that [ __ ] story so you created a
further
story of me like she gave you a face
tattoo on her mind
she has a knife that she pulled out of
her little bike basket i don't know what
it is but i think i do get a lot of road
rage for some reason or like i do have
like
anger bouts or whatever but i've never
really had to throw down i think i scare
people before
anything happens so i'm more all barking
no bite
yeah i could see that typical cancer
have you
ever been in a fight um no
yeah i mean either physical i've gotten
my ass beat before like in elementary
school
i got beat up by this girl in elementary
school and then my friend i wrestled
with my friend it was play wrestling but
i think she took it a little too far she
was trying to dominate me
and she was stronger than me so she
pinned me down and i was very upset
about it but i was like ah
funny we're playing but yeah that
[ __ ] annoyed me
um you didn't throw a punch no no i saw
yeah i've never fought anyone but i just
get so aggressive
and my anger comes out where i think
people are like whoa okay you know we
don't
gotta fight so i've never actually had
to fight and i'm happy with that i don't
i don't actually ever really want to
hurt anyone or hit anyone i've never
i don't want to hit anyone yeah well
gina would only do it to defend somebody
yeah yeah yeah i don't ever swing first
yeah i feel like you would be more of a
cutter than a hitter
yeah like you would be a switchblade a
knife right now
well also you don't swing first because
legal reasons yeah you have a lawyer
i don't see you hitting anyone but i do
see you standing up for yourself
yes yeah now yeah
i would lay down and take it you're just
so feminine and dainty i can't imagine
you like physically hurting anything
yeah i'd be more of a hair puller yeah
and a crasher
i would kick i was gonna say like i
every time i've gotten so
enraged by someone i'm more likely to
hurt myself than to hurt
them like i get so mad and i start like
hurting like just punching a [ __ ]
wall
that she punches the pillow and it hurts
i do this thing where i was like
i crossed my arms and then i actually
dig my nails into my arm when i'm mad
and it for some reason it feels good
they're nail digging i do that too
it's weird yeah if i were to ever get
into a bar fight i think the first
person i'd tag in is just
yeah i'd swing a chair or something if i
had to i mean i
i'm not probably good at fighting but
i'll probably fight really dirty and win
i just i don't want to be in that
situation though like i really don't i
have no desire to fight anyone
i'd run and hide behind one of steve's
legs
can they at least record for us so we
can put on world yeah thanks
what's next george gina carries a knife
or a taser
i have a little one in my bag right now
a taser i
have at home and i'm not gonna lie
sometimes an arsenal
at home yeah yeah um the taser is kind
of
scary to have because sometimes at night
when i'm like bored and i can't sleep
like the first thing that pops on my
head is i wonder what getting taste
feels like oh my god
yeah i haven't why is that the first
thing yeah sometimes he's gonna
maybe i'll fall asleep when i can't fall
asleep i think about i'm like
what porn story will get me to come the
fastest so i fall asleep
story in your head that you play yeah
like i have like you guys don't have
masturbation like um
fantasy like yeah like i have like ones
i shuffle between sometimes this one's
not doing it so i shuffle to the next
one
[ __ ] storyline it's just like come
just physical yeah i need storyline
i feel like gina's on my level yeah i do
that yeah yeah yeah yeah
like i need to like the dominance aspect
of like like seeing a visual i don't
know yeah
no i started laughing because i remember
that one time where uh
gina was very upset and she just kept
sending us photos of all the weapons
like a mace like what's that thing
that's like it's got points on oh yeah
like a [ __ ] yeah i think it's called
a mace no
i think so yeah you have like all these
like old school [ __ ] looking [ __ ] i
was really mad about something
one day and i sent into the group chat
just pictures of me holding various just
weapons walking dead weapons yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah my baseball bat
yeah so like i have like a baseball bat
with a barbed wire wrapped around it
and then to send a picture of my gun and
then various knives i have
um my bedroom knives i have my car knife
i have my bag knife i have my pocket
knife you sleep with a pillow
i mean a knife under your pillow it's
right next to my bed because i heard
that that prevents you from having
nightmares oh yeah my grandfather my
great-grandfather used to sleep with a
knife in his pillow well [ __ ] let me go
dump my [ __ ] kitchen into my bedroom
because i do have a chef's knife
yeah because when steve was out of town
for a week like i was so scared and we
i didn't at the time like well we have a
a g
word we have a we have a gun
but i was you know just like what if i
don't have time to run for that and like
i'm sleeping like i'm buying
so it's the thing i could grab the
closest but it has a sheath on it like
so and it's bright purple
oh my gosh i don't know exactly which
one you have because i have the same one
okay if i could stab my
bright purple knife i'm gonna be very
upset damn it come on
i don't have nightmares so i wonder if
that yeah maybe i don't have a knife
i don't really have nightmares either i
just don't have a lot of nightmares i
should probably sleep here
y'all are in bad terms with geo jess is
trying to influ
jess is trying to leave the influencer
life please don't i love you all right
y'all keep [ __ ] thinking that we hate
you or something we don't
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] first she
started the podcast yeah she's our she's
our podcast mom
um i actually was at geo's house a
couple times over the summer before the
pandemic got really bad but yeah
i think what's happening is like people
have been following jk for so long and
seen
like the group together um
but you know like as years have gone by
like people have
kind of shifted into their own personal
projects like we were on this project
together but then you know
geo and even bose had like other things
that they wanted to work on more
and i feel like as adults you know we
spend more time with the people that
we're like directly
working with yeah co-workers like who do
you actually have to see for your job
every day
and you know it just kind of
transitioned to where we saw like less
and less of her but i have
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] i don't same
and it's it's cool like i don't know
i've been on youtube for
13 years now or 14 years now and i've
gone through different groups of like
youtubers and it's not like
we don't we're not friends anymore it's
just like we were all doing sketches
together
then everyone kind of splintered into
different projects then you find a new
group
and then like when you see each other
again it's like really fun because it's
like oh [ __ ] what's what's been up with
you
yeah exactly yeah and then you just tame
it you usually like you hang out after
work like
yeah i feel like as an adult maybe i
don't know how old the people are that
assume that we don't like
geo or bows or anything but it's like
when you're an adult like in your 30s
most of your life is just about your
career and your work so like
people kind of start to fall to the
wayside just on accident because like if
you're not at work with me
then i'm you know yeah and they're not
going to see you as often but they're
just married
you go home with your spouse with the
kid and stuff too time
time separation is yeah no
delegate and then jess is not leaving
okay
jess is moving physically to texas
because she's a [ __ ]
i understand that assumption i
understand that assumption because i've
i went through definitely especially
during the darkest part of the pandemic
i was like oh my god i [ __ ] i'm
hating social media i'm starting to feel
like
more negative about a lot of things in
life because i was just definitely
getting
darker into a hole because i was alone a
lot because of the academics so i was
just like
i don't even want to be on social media
anymore [ __ ] this [ __ ] part of me still
believes that because i do feel
more healthy when i'm not on social
media as much
um but i think now i've gone through the
dark part of it and now i've found like
a happy medium where like i can post a
little bit maybe i'll take breaks for a
while
um i am going to go back to texas and
kind of have a little bit more of a real
world life with my nine to five like
just that
same boring life that i had before that
i didn't appreciate now i want to kind
of get back into that but also have this
on the side
so i think that's the healthy balance
that i'm going to get into but i also
i i keep hearing this thing too like
like in the comments the people will be
like oh they're going to replace jess
with someone else so they're going to
replace
somebody like with who yeah no there's
no rep
there might be additions karen's are
hard to come by
we got ours she's a privilege we need
her
she gets out of trouble know this but
like we own this [ __ ] like this
we legally own this show you can't
replace me [ __ ] i own hats
exactly i have shares in them
you can't get rid of me i'll [ __ ]
call your manager you know what i'm
saying
no but i do think that like originally
with social media it was intended to be
like a side thing and then
you know in the past 10 years it's
become an actual
career to just have that be your career
but it used to be like you know you had
your job and then you post on that on
the side and i think that
when you get too consumed with the
social media or when that becomes your
job and your life and everything
um it it can lead to like more anxiety
more depression
um it does worse mental health and so i
think having like
a life outside of it and then balancing
it will do a lot of
i can't i'm not my personality type
doesn't do well being entirely on the
internet i just can't handle
[Music]
that being everything you never thought
you would either no i never even wanted
to be but i just kind of took advantage
of what was in front of me
at the time you walked through the doors
that were open i walked through the
doors that were open and i saw what was
on the other side i'm like okay that's
cool but that's not going to be my
everything but i'm not
leaving i'm not you know especially
because i do still want to i
because i know as well that if we don't
have a reason
to see each other as much like like we
said would you like
our friendships might fall off a little
bit so i'm definitely holding on to this
so that i can hold on to our friendships
because i know how [ __ ] busy people
start getting replacing uh
you know their things in their life are
so clingy
they have to yell at me to hang out i
know [ __ ] gina like today after the
shoot i'm like i looked right into her
eyes i'm like
you have to show up you need to show up
to hang out
you cannot cancel this [ __ ] hangout
i'm telling you right now
you're coming because i'm pretty
anti-social even when it comes to my
friends like my best friend
lives my best friend since high school
lives two miles from me and i see her
like once every three months dude we're
so similar
yeah my two best friends from high
school we see each other twice a year
like once on someone's birthday and like
once for christmas we do a cookie party
thing
and it's like no time has passed like we
all get it
and like sometimes we'll get into a text
chat but it's like very rare
yeah um but you know it's like that love
is always there exactly
so just because you guys don't see us
all hanging out doesn't mean we don't
get along yeah i have my friend at home
my friend
um i've known her since elementary
school but we started hanging out more
in middle school and
i can still to this day not talk to her
for a year yeah
for 14 months 16 months and then i'll
call her and we'll talk for two hours
just like nothing happens
that's how you know it's a real
friendship adult friendships are a
little i don't know maybe a little
different than y'all
understand but that being said gina
better not [ __ ] cancel on us
yeah okay no i'm dragging your ass
to this hangout i will hide behind
steve's leg
what do we got next nikki loki likes
hentai and there's
have you ever bought it i have never
looked at hentai in my life i
i recently i i don't even know if i
actually know what it is
it's cartoon anime right yeah like anime
anime
[Music]
his username on instagram is literally
hence i love her 69
so i don't know i don't think i'd be
against it because i think my
introduction into sexual feelings came
through cartoons
there was a specific scene and fievel
goes west i don't know if it's five goes
by
yeah okay he gets caught by the cat and
gets wrapped up in a burrito
and i like got turned on by that like
the thought of being like you can't move
you like have no control
but i didn't know what those feelings
were when i was a kid so like
i don't know the thought of an octopus
or grabbing me with the tentacles or
what i always hear about tentacle porn
it comes with hentai i don't know maybe
that maybe that would turn me on i can't
imagine
it doesn't feel real to me so i i don't
know if i would come to it
but i'm not against it nikki has a
burrito fetish
i'm open well that's not a secret
nikki schedules get-togethers for the
group jess is most likely no i was early
today
an hour early most likely to be late and
gina most likely
was late today i was the latest oh my
god that's exactly what was
that's exactly what happened today but i
don't schedule [ __ ] nikki
yeah i schedule everyone she schedules
but other than that it's pretty spot-on
yeah yeah good job good job but also i
have to protest the being late thing
because i try
so hard to not be late and to like shed
that stigma off of me and it's just that
today was really bad
i mean if you're trying to shut a stigma
you can't do the thing trying is
different than doing
yeah we love you but no no so the reason
why i say trying is because
for the most part i'm not late i would
say in my mind you don't stick out as
the latest
yeah that's gina that's yeah it's either
super late or doesn't
it doesn't come oh yeah i only deal in
extremes yeah yeah
that's true but yeah shout out to our
sponsor doordash
so doordash connects you with the
restaurants that you love
right now and right to your door and now
you can get the grocery
essentials you need with doordash as
well so get drinks
snacks and other household items
delivered in under
an hour but yeah all you have to do is
open the doordash app you choose what
you want from where you want and your
items will be left safely outside of
your door with the contactless delivery
drop-off setting
with over 300 000 partners in the us
puerto rico canada and australia
you can support your neighborhood's
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like
chipotle i can't ever say it right
outside
not scientology like i can't say it
because i used to say like chipotle
popeyes and cheesecake factory so for a
limited time
our listeners can get 25 percent off and
zero delivery fees on their first order
of fifteen dollars or more
when you download the doordash app and
enter code mood
that's twenty five percent off up to a
ten dollar
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash
app in the app store and enter code mood
don't forget that's code mood forward 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
and what goes in must come out oh god it
sure does and when it comes out
sometimes it don't come out too
clean but if you do want it to be clean
we have hello tushy
um i feel like wiping your butt dry is
weird it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever you're smearing it everywhere
so
you should be useful yeah you're not
taking you're not removing it
it's like imagine trying to clean a
carpet with
a spill in it with just dry paper towels
what if you use your ass juice all right
um
so we have hello tishi no that's why you
have holidays
to wash off that ass juice oh geez what
is wrong with you people
now the brand new hella tissue 3.0
modern bidet attachment is here and it's
stylish eco-friendly and easy to install
and affordable
hello tissue 3.0 doesn't just cleanse
your butt butt with a precise stream of
fresh water
it cleans itself before and after it's
used it
has the smart spray that automatically
cleans itself it's a self-cleaning
nozzle
it attaches to your existing toilet
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing and cuts toilet paper use by
eighty percent
that means the hell of tissue bidet pays
for itself in just a few months
plus every hello tissue bidet attachment
comes with a 60-day risk-free guarantee
and a 12-month warranty go to
hellotishie.com
big mood to get 10 off plus free
shipping this is a special offer for big
mood listeners so go to hellotushy.com
big mood for 10 off that's
hellotushin.com
big mood you all wish you could have
grown up together you all wish you had
grown up together
yeah that'd be so fun dude okay so i
know gina and i would have been friends
in high school because we both hung out
with the same
type of people what kind of crowds did
you guys hang out with i had
i went through phases so i had a phase
where i was like a
rocker chick whatever like yeah yeah
like emails
i think we all had that yeah it was
middle
school and that was my middle school
post high school yeah i got more
punk but yeah i did the whole rocker
thing like the corn and limb biscuit and
all that in middle school
so yeah we all would have hugged out
yeah yeah sure and then like
high school i kind of was more uh well
early middle school i was like more
preppy
kind of like cutesy whatever and then
late middle school was the emo phase and
then in
and entering high school that's when i
hit my hip hop
like chola phase and that's where eminem
comes in
yeah and then aft and then when i moved
to mexico i was in the middle of high
school
and then so in mexico i tried to into
like banda
no not about chapstick it's a type of
music no it was actually banda
and electronic like edm like psychedelic
trans because we i would go to raves
with my sister if you have braids in
your hair i could
picture that yeah yeah gina's making
braids in my hair and then
um and then late high school i was just
kind of like a mix of it all
oh no no i was more like reggaeton stuff
because then by the time i got back
that's when dragonton was
popping so i had all like a whole bunch
of different i think we all could have
been friends
i think so too do you think we'd all
have developed the same personality if
we found friends like this
so early i don't think so yeah i think
our friendship now is a product of not
having girlfriends
i agree exactly yeah i have girlfriends
but not like
i don't know it was different right it
was like one or two maybe but then
there's still a lot of
like cattiness that comes from being in
high school
right now i had the same best friend
from kindergarten
all the way through high school but
wow yeah that's a long time well we did
have our phases
where like she had a different best
friend and i had a different business i
hate that [ __ ]
like well i can't be your best friend
because i'm already her best friend
you [ __ ] hate that's so funny but
like just that we would spend more of
our time with the other
yeah but we always had that we always
maintain that connection
my best friends quote unquote the ones
that i called my best friends they all
had other best friends but they we spent
most of our time together
but like it just feels like i'm a side
chick but like you're ashamed of me
yeah so funny okay so tiff gets annoyed
when she
gets ignored i would say yeah jess is an
introvert um gina unintentionally flirts
with everyone
and nikki overthinks everything yeah
i agree with the overthinking for sure
although i will say once i got adhd
medication
it has helped a lot with that like i
feel like my anxiety went completely
down
i don't overthink as much i do analyze
the [ __ ] out of things in research but
i don't over think as much that's good
yeah
do i flirt a lot i think you have a
flirty persona
yeah but i wouldn't say you flirt a lot
yeah no no
as i sit here playing with another
woman's hair yeah she's brain i'm trying
to picture like when a boy's here like a
like if you were yeah unintentionally
i'd already i don't see it no
yeah i don't think so either like you're
more like more like bro with them like
yeah you know i think maybe maybe people
could take that as being flirty because
you're just
you get along with guys so easily yeah i
think that it could be misconstrued in
that way
but i don't think you're in here with
women yeah yeah that's what i was about
to say
usually it's more with women when it
comes out what was yours
that i'm an i introvert i don't
know because you get your energy from
socializing yeah that's how they say
that
it comes back to whether you're an
introvert or extrovert like what you get
charged by
and i feel like you get charged by
hanging out with people yeah like you're
like steve
yeah whereas like gina and i charge by
being alone
because like if i imagine doing like
being a youtuber right like i could only
do it with people
like i couldn't do it alone i don't know
if that goes into
the test of like if i'm introverted
because like the only way i could create
content or even have a conversation or
think of anything creative whatsoever is
because i'm bouncing off of other people
and then whenever we're in a group of
friends or like at a get-together you
don't just like
hide in a corner you know you're really
social so i don't know
i wouldn't classify you as like very
introverted either
and then also my assumption it's like
who wouldn't get it
being ignored yeah yeah it's like come
on i used to get
like super triggered getting an uh
interrupted
interrupted annoyed because of jk news
yeah like that was
such a difficult environment to like
constantly
explained over and constantly being
transplanted
um and then you're trying to do your job
too yeah exactly
so yeah like actually like right here
like just right now i i got
you guys talked over me but i don't get
annoyed or irritated because it doesn't
come from the same place
of like of like constant disrespect yeah
it feels like
on that set but yeah i guess i would be
obviously very annoyed i think they're
projecting
that they see you get ignored a lot um
so that's what they're noticing yeah
next assumption
that all of you are pretentious [ __ ]
and i'm right to this day
lmfao all of you are pretentious [ __ ]
and i'm i'm right to this day
to this day what does that mean that we
are pretending that we were pretentious
that he thought it originally yeah that
he thought it originally and it's still
true pretentious pretentious
[Laughter]
possibly yeah well the lmfao is already
like
uh isn't it like i'm kidding pretentious
i'm joking
right that's how george was reading it
okay i have no idea
like elitist is that like elitist kind
of sort of
i don't know i'm lazy as [ __ ] like i
feel like
if anything i go this the sack of [ __ ]
route where i'm like
i was like he's a total piece of [ __ ]
yeah i was like self-deprecating like
for most of i had to stop
self-deprecating
because that was like my whole humor
base like in my 20s and like the start
of my youtube career
um yeah and my stand-up and everything
was like very self-deprecating
and it started to actually affect my
self-esteem and i had to go like in
therapy i felt like i had to
stop doing that as frequently
but yeah then it becomes you know i was
doing that to like you know makes other
people more comfortable
to if you start off with
self-deprecation but then when you stop
doing that i'm like oh no
do they think that i'm that you think
you're the [ __ ] yeah yeah because i'm
not self-deprecating anymore because i'm
trying really really hard tonight i only
like it when women
humble themselves if you don't humble
yourself in a pretentious [ __ ]
so i guess i am but then i started the
chic wife life because of that where i
like just go over the top like i'm so
[ __ ] chic
i'm on a vacation all day i'm constantly
in between like self-deprecating and
then god complex
right yeah so like the trash is god on
earth yeah
cheeto god oh god yeah it's like an
ethereal goddess but then like
cheeto dust wipe all over her first of
all i'm better than you but don't give
me a second
like a cat clawing at the couch right
next to you my cat's
pissed on my gown calm down
when you share so much about yourselves
fans have crazy assumptions
yeah that's true yeah i think they're
raised on youtube
craziness yeah like because a lot of
people do a lot of crazy [ __ ] for clout
so they're just like
they're like that you must be like that
or even like presenting an image
that isn't who they are behind the
scenes like that's so
normal now that like i guess it could be
hard to see when people are
being genuine no yeah so then the more
we share
too it's like they they like we probably
share too much information or they just
don't
receive all the information but then
they'll make assumptions out of
something that has already been shared
you know what i mean yeah yeah like
okay here's the truth and then they'll
be like oh it must be this other thing
even though they already received
we've already explained it yeah like
it's already been explained exactly
they're just not
yeah they're not following enough
information some people i feel like are
you know when like in those detective
shows where they have the strings like
attached
they like take videos from like five
years ago and it's a string attached
them to one here and they're like
okay i think she said this because way
back here in this video she said this
and then i think did they're like
[ __ ] detectives and i'm like wow
you're
way overcomplicated
like we are not that like imagine trying
to keep track of
all that like i guess it's an
entertainment game it's just a game yeah
i forget that we're real people and
we're actually sharing
our real lives our real actual
experiences
and then they're just like they receive
it as like a soap opera
yeah i have to try to remember to not
take it personally because i'm like
how can you de personalize me that much
like to
to create this fake thing and then add a
bunch of drama to it or i'm just like
this makes no sense i don't understand
it but
yeah i i wasn't as much of a child of
the internet as i'm sure a lot of
they are them are so i i just don't
understand it but
it's provocative no one knows what it
means
there's a there's a website that was
like calculating net worth and the
assumption was
i was worth 13 million i'm like wow
someone said that you have a
you have a a vacation home in hawaii or
something else i'll take that too
focus doesn't have that yeah can we go
yeah let's go
how come we haven't been i'm trying to
hide it jesus christ now people are
going to [ __ ] ask
it's like a little cave and a dinky
little
uh jess has a heavy texas accent but
hides it to blend in with california
people my accent is what you see
show us your real voice stop hitting it
oh my god there it is i can't believe
that i can now take
off this mask and be my real son
i feel so much better now i'm i hope you
guys will accept me
from me gabby can you add the ice cubes
clinking
bless
no that's funny but doesn't it like
doesn't a little bit of the toy come
kind of come out when i go home
home because casey definitely like his
texan comes in i cannot picture cases i
don't want to hear that
it's not it's not so heavy i guess i'm
exaggerating texas playing is a little
different from a lot of stuff in the
south like someone from alabama sounds a
little different from someone from
georgia from someone from
you know they all kind of have their own
little things but that's how california
is but in different parts of california
oh yeah the beach town people the valley
we're not
miranda all the time a lot of texas is
just mexican people so it's just spanish
so it's not all just [ __ ] white
cowboys it's a lot of
mexicans california too yeah
yeah i know i actually lost my chicana
like it used to be heavy like it's so
cute when you do it yeah
yeah sometimes i love it it's one of my
i call it when my tongue gets lazy and
so like i
flatten out my tongue and that's when i
can really speak my chicana
but i've not done it for so long that
sometimes i forget
i see you when you speak spanish
sometimes you do get the lazy mouth and
then your words just completely run into
each other
yeah even when i'm speaking spanish yeah
i just got back from mexico and so like
when i was there
i'm trying to speak spanish but then
it's all [ __ ] broken up because my
brain can't make the connections
and then my mother is like not making
the [ __ ] right noises
so i'm like damn um out of the four of
you tiff is a hello kitty fan
sanrio fan she likes cute things out of
the four of you
tiff is a hello kitty fan a sanrio fan
she likes cute things gina's offended
she's wagging her hello kitty socks
she's stomping with her hello kitty
stocks
i think they said that just to piss off
gina i know right like
first of all [ __ ] what the [ __ ] do you
think you're talking to you can hear
merch drive fast eat ass looks like a
sanrio
everything about gina is sanrio yeah but
tiff does like small things
i love tiny things but they have to be
functional things they can't just be
toys i'm really particular about that
but sanrio stuff
um i don't hate it but i would never
buy something for myself that has a
hello kitty on it i would never
you would never be that trashy yeah i'm
not calling it trashy i'm just saying
it's not for me
yeah a wrong assumption clearly that was
a troll wrong
i used to be obsessed with pachaco in
fourth grade i had pachaco everything
yeah did he disappear i know i don't
hear about him anymore
the dog i like growing up oh the frog
yeah i liked him i know none of this
nerd [ __ ]
and then i like the the bat i forget was
oh yeah
yeah like that was my second favorite i
went to the sanrio headquarters once i
was um
invited to go and it felt like walking
to the gates of
my it's like as an asian yeah it's like
meeting god
i'm gonna go to the headquarters too
because it's just such a special place
yeah right it's so cute yeah like i
don't
make that my aesthetic but i still think
it's really cute like i can't admire it
i did go to sanrio store a lot when i
was a little kid
my mom would buy me like the mystery
packs
yeah so i did enjoy it dude i wanted the
beeper cover so bad but my parents
wouldn't let me get a beeper
she got the cover without the beeper
need a cardboard one
are you talking about a pager yes you
call them beepers yeah yeah they they
didn't go with you i don't know anyways
we're too [ __ ] old
that's true that's what we really
learned out of it but honestly like
like people still have them in high
school when i was in high school really
i'm [ __ ] old yeah i found this is
like the same age as me
thank you mm-hmm tiff and nikki talk to
themselves when they're alone
what about you i don't you don't i'm
actually surprised
i would assume that too oh interesting
what about it because we have lonely
childhoods
i don't know i actually so my friend was
a tv so i would just consume i wouldn't
i wouldn't do that you wouldn't interact
yeah i was dead brains so
that's how i am dead yeah i wouldn't
interact that's why i don't have much of
an
imagination i talk to myself constantly
yeah i don't i'm always like where did
you put that i don't know i think it
went over here okay
no i think it's not there there was
another so my dad
my dad would talk to himself all the
time out loud
out loud and so after my mom and dad
divorced
my mom was like so salty towards my dad
so anything that wasn't even remotely
related to my dad she would like [ __ ] on
it so every time she would always be
like
because she would talk to herself
sometimes in the car so like mom were
you talking to yourself and she'd be
like
no only crazy people talk to themselves
and i'm like jesus we're just talking to
yourself
all you have to do is add a vlog camera
then it's normal it's a career here you
go
boom there you go crazy people that is
the only time i talk to myself but it's
not even to myself
i actually is to myself but it's to my
future self yes
i always like interesting try to connect
with my future i give her no almost like
editing nikki
um make sure you put like a bubble right
here
that's cute
rich as [ __ ] but uh still pretend she's
one of us low lives
how else could she afford a vacation
home yeah
you have a hawaiian vacation home gina
is secretly rich as [ __ ] but she
pretends to be one of
us low lives how else she could afford
how else could she afford a hawaiian
vacation home
why do people think you have a hawaiian
vacation home i've never heard that have
you ever
i barely have friends i've seen you in
hawaii oh i used to go to hawaii like
almost every year oh really a few times
a year yeah a lot
yeah gina just has connections and like
somewhere to stay in every country
that's true in almost every city yeah oh
yeah
it's because you were an escort yeah
there we go
gina is [ __ ] gina's [ __ ] popular okay
everyone who meets her just loves
that's another assumption that she would
always get it's like gina's an escort
how else can she fly everywhere
stay places how else could a person do
that how does one
afford things how does one take a two
hundred dollar flight
yeah yeah and then i don't know a hotel
like a hundred dollar hotel
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] how dare she
she must be an escort i don't you're
never going to get rid of that
never no one will ever believe that
you're not having sex for money yeah
you've never earned every dollar how
many hours you work
[ __ ] streaming and all that other
[ __ ] like it's gonna be a comment it's
gonna
right i always tell people like if i was
an escort
i wouldn't be here you wouldn't be doing
way bigger [ __ ] right i wouldn't
be here yeah are you kidding me i would
be [ __ ] like i'd be sucking dick in
another country trying to get some more
vacation homes you'd be on like a 37th
floor of a beijing [ __ ] peninsula
you wouldn't be here i'd be in a bentley
right now doing
great like railing lines of coke are you
kidding me yeah you could be an escort
but you choose not to because you do
have a soul in there
somewhere well escorts have souls
i'm kidding you come at me
the biggest [ __ ] feminist [ __ ] on
this show don't come for me [ __ ]
yeah in my cat cult we use kitty poo
litter box solution
kitty poo club is convenient it's an
all-in-one monthly litter box solution
what's really cool about it is you don't
really even need to have a litter box
because
the box becomes the litter box and then
instead of switching out the litter
each month where you have to scrub like
the your litter box
you just throw it all into the recycling
everything is
eco-friendly leak-proof and there's a
fun design for every season
when the month is up you just recycle
the box and kitty poo club will
automatically deliver a new one to you
no changing used litter and no more
clean the box
so they provide the litter and the box
you can customize your order based on
how many cats you have
and choose from four different litter
types so i have one of each
so because four cats four different
litters they can pick kittypoo club has
no risk a no risk satisfaction guarantee
and you can easily customize or cancel
anytime
and right now kittypoo club is offering
you 20 off your first order plus a free
dome free scoop
and free shipping when you set up auto
ship by going to kitty poo club dot com
slash mood just go to kittypoopclub.com
to get 20 off your first order plus a
free dome scoop and free shipping when
you set up autoship that's kittypoo
club.com mood and
now we would like to take a minute to
shout out on one of our newest sponsors
rothys i love
these shoes they're so comfortable all
right i thought
you know tiff got them first yeah we all
got to get a pair for free to try them
before we did the ad
tiff was like oh my god they're so
comfortable i was like yeah whatever
okay you know they're shoes
you gotta break them in before they're
out no they were immediately
these shoes have zero break-in period it
feels like a sock it's
so weird they're so cool so the style
that i got i got them with my
nine-to-five job
in mind because i'm just like gearing up
to get ready to go back to work and be
all professional so i got those
pointed toe flats in the cranberry plaid
so cute so chic by the way i love it
i got the i get the point too i like it
you got the point too you got them in
red though right
the red ones yeah i love those um but
rothies are available in a range of
styles
that come in ever-changing array of
colors prints and patterns their shoes
are knit
with thread made from plastic water
bottles yeah they're recycled they're
ultra comfortable though that's weird
so like you get to kind of save the
planet and also like really enjoy your
feet
and look cute as hell too yeah they're
really cute so cute rothy's has
transformed nearly 100 million bottles
into beautiful shoes handbags and face
masks
oh that's pretty crazy the shoes also
are fully machine washable you know when
i used to work
i would wear the same pair of flats to
work all the time and they would start
to stink because flats make your feet
they do they do but yeah these are
machine washable which is great
check out all the amazing shoes bags and
masks available right now at rothys.com
big mood make sure to use our link so
they know that we sent you so we get
paid you know what i'm saying that's
rothys.com
r-o-t-h-y-s rafi's
dot com slash big mood style and
sustainability meet to create your new
favorites
head to rothys.com big mood today
uh i hope these don't come across as
personal attacks [ __ ] i'll kill you
oh you're just gonna start i hope this
doesn't come off as a personal attack
no offense but i'm ready to fight no
offense
uh jess has some trust issues so it's
hard for her to empathize with god
gina is actually the most sensitive
first of all [ __ ] lower your voice
what the [ __ ] you think you're talking
to she protects yourself by exposing
yourself first
uh tiff despite sharing her
vulnerabilities a lot is actually the
most resilient
and nikki is sweet but sometimes it's
hard for her to speak her mind about
things because it'll break the peace
you are kind of a peacekeeper whereas i
would just say the [ __ ] and break the
piece you won't
that's true you like things to be yeah
the thing is is that like i feel like
people are so misunderstood so even if i
disagree with someone i would rather
like
try to understand them and sometimes if
you just say something like
just lay it on the table they'll shut
down because they feel attacked and i
would
rather like understand them and disagree
and like politely from a neutral
position than
to like throw rocks um i also
i think just being in the same industry
for a long time you find out how small
that circle is
yeah and if you just burn bridges with
everyone that pisses you off or says
like
you know something mean or like or rubs
you the wrong way
you're not going to be able to stay
stick around long because
um you know it just happens like people
have egos in this industry people
have their own agendas people have all
kinds of different [ __ ] going on
and if you can't keep the peace like
you don't want to work with you people
won't want to work with you yeah and so
yeah i mean like i have opinions about
people but for the most part i think
everyone's just trying
to make something work like with their
life so
i try to come at it with that
perspective of like okay
let's calm down and just look at what's
going on in
the calmer emotions you're so good at
that yeah you're really good at that
you have like a superpower there that
being said i think i'm very sensitive
yeah nicki is probably more easy to
break
yeah gina is very sensitive but i don't
think she'll break as
fast yeah mm-hmm tiff's definitely
resilient
what is it what does it say i mean it's
just strong like you'll you make it
through you're making it through
everything
yeah you persevere you do yeah you
really do
yeah i think so i think anyone that's
been a [ __ ] teen mom is resilient as
[ __ ]
yeah i would have tossed that kid that's
like one of the hardest things ever
that's true and then what was it the
second part about me
that you are sen the most sensitive of
the group but you
hide it by putting putting yourself
yeah oh yeah i mean i i put out
things first because like you can't
you can't hurt my feelings by making fun
of something i'm already making fun of
you know and that's what i always tell
people like if you can laugh at yourself
it takes the power away from people who
want to bring you down
yeah yeah yeah what was what about jess
trust issues trust issues yeah i mean
obviously if you've had the life i've
had
all of us i think um well not maybe
nikki quite as much
but like me having the drug addicted mom
tiff like you had a lot of [ __ ] going on
gina
yeah abuse like there's just i mean
obviously i think it's hard to find a
person who doesn't have trust issues
true yeah but for me i think what i've
been going through is just
kind of a little bit of a rebirth where
i was hating myself and blaming myself
for a lot of things that were happening
but now
i'm allowing myself to go you know what
actually some sometimes
other people are actually responsible
for what they're doing for me and i
don't need to internalize it i'm going
to actually
be like no that's shitty it's shitty of
you to use me it's shitty of you to lie
to me it's shitty of you to do that i'm
standing up for myself a little bit more
now
maybe i've gone a little too far in my
vocalization of holding men accountable
for the things that i've been through
like an overcorrection right but then
you know
and i get that um and i think i'm
calming down a little bit more now but
like yeah i've definitely gone through a
period where i'm like you know what i
it is okay for me to say you know it's
shitty when men do this and i don't
think they should
and you know i i want to protect women
and i want to protect
them from blaming themselves for the
things that people have put them through
it's not always your fault when someone
uses you you need to wake up
you know like that's shitty stop but
yeah so yeah
trust issues for sure but that's normal
i think
yeah i mean i would say that from you
know shitty relationships and stuff
i i think that mind healed from being in
a healthy relationship
but it took like you know the first year
was hard
you know and then as you learn to trust
then your trust issues go away
right yeah i trust basically only myself
as far as a romantic male to female
relationship
i trust being alone it's easier than
dealing with someone else but i do
have hope that someone would be able to
break that wall back down and i could
you know trust someone people have to
earn your trust too because i learned
that
also in business i was way too trusting
in the beginning i was very way too
trusting of all the wrong
obviously wrong types because i just
thought well i'm a good person
so they'll be just as good yeah as i am
to them but you tend to think people
have your same intentions but they don't
yeah
you all rarely hang out outside of
social media i'd say that's pretty true
that's pretty true
yeah but i don't know a lot of people
that do hang out
outside of social media that often
especially during the pandemic
like last year was a one-off that was
like really that was really tough
yeah yeah i feel like we had just
started all hanging out together in 2009
we were just becoming friends we would
have dinner yeah
but see that's that's the thing that i
would kind of disagree about
us not hanging out outside of social
media because there have been
countless times that we hang out that
not one of us brings out a camera or
like posts about it
and so oh yeah
in my opinion yeah more often than not
on my vlogs i'm like [ __ ] i forgot to
vlog
yeah i think for me the way the reason
why i'm agreeing with it is because we
only hang out
maybe two or three times in a month and
one of those times is for work
or maybe two of those times is for work
and then the other one like we won't
even mention it or even probably post a
story or anything like we'll just be at
someone's house and no one will say
anything
um but i can't agree that it's wrong
because i feel like if we were actually
hanging out like
what people expect it would be like at
least once a week or two or three i
genuinely believe that we would be if it
wasn't for this past year
like yeah how we were starting off like
the this group and like how tight-knit
we were
in the chat yeah we were talking all the
time and all that stuff but then
it's just been a crazy pandemic yeah
also you moved
really far one direction i moved really
far the other direction
yeah and then gina never leaves their
house so that i mean we had to drag that
shot yeah for pretty much everything
true and honestly like i kind of needed
last year to as with the excuse of the
pandemic because i
felt obliged i really like being alone
and like
being focused on something i need to do
and i felt very interrupted by all the
social obligations
and i have a hard time saying no because
i don't want people to take it
personally so
i like would do i would bend over
backwards trying to make every social
obligation and at the end of the day i
was so drained on
when i actually wanted to work on my
stuff so last year was cool to be able
to just like work on my stuff but
i also think that we would have hung out
a lot more had that not happened and now
i
i think the balance has happened where
i'm like i'm ready to hang out again
yeah i'm leaving now i just want to hang
out during the daytime all the time
but she says two to three times a month
i'm like [ __ ] there's four weekends in
a month that's all
without you're taking up three of a four
like that's fine yeah yeah that's good
barely that's still a lot of haters for
most of the three
well that that seems like a lot
pre-pandemic but that's what we used to
hang out like
at least two or three out of the four
weekends pre-pandemic but now it's been
like maybe once a month yeah yeah
yeah walk down so that's where i'm like
well i barely see [ __ ] anyway only
for work so
yeah it was hard too because we did have
covid so yeah
there was like a a month or two where
like we couldn't
yeah we couldn't even go to work i don't
know how i [ __ ] skated through i mean
i did stay home a lot but
i skated through so far yeah and you got
your backs
only only the first one oh yeah nikki
used to be a model
yes but not the kind of model that
you're thinking of
i was a model for 80d medication
i was a model for cat food bags but only
in the latin market because because
you are a latino brown for the american
brand
so random it's so random i almost
modeled for trojan
but then they were like nah she takes it
rob
they knew i didn't believe it yeah
um i was a child model too i modeled for
lands in catalogs
and i modeled uh for the country of
greece for
an ibm print ad during the olympics
yeah so many descriptions i love it
that's so random
that's what working in hollywood is like
until you finally land something big
yeah yeah you saw this rant
whatever you just say yes to everything
i love it because nikki keeps saying
words and i don't know where it's going
you know and it just ends up i i'm happy
at the end every time
i love it happy surprise yeah gina is a
k-pop star
that's stupid yeah i'm not a permanent
singer
yeah right
maybe you could walk down a hallway like
a cake pop she can't even pretend to
because i can't even be ladylike to be a
k-pop star yeah i want to see you do one
of those dances though
oh yeah k-pop dances that's true
you all have a high sex drive we all
have a high sex
i do but i haven't had sex in a long
time common misconceptions of women but
they expect us all to be
vixens and [ __ ] tell us more let's
unpack this
that's actually the expectation that
women don't have a sex drive that
they're
yeah they won't have sex
after marriage you don't have sex
anymore because she never wants it
no it's uh it's like the like
there is that that expectation on women
usually like generally culturally
speaking there's that expectation on
women that they
should always want to [ __ ] [ __ ] anywhere
[ __ ] anyone all this other [ __ ] like
it it's in the comments you are book she
talks about it really well really i
haven't noticed
yeah i've always heard the opposite like
women because that's why we get called
hoes and [ __ ] and stuff if we sleep
around too much
so a lady should be a lady and we're
reserved
especially in a relationship like
there's this expectation that if you're
in a relationship
it's expectation that you should always
as
a woman you should always be wanting to
[ __ ] huh
huh until you're married well i get that
i get that maybe there's an expectation
but i don't think that
people think that's real i think a lot
of people
honestly feel like women won't put out
like
the dead bedroom things yeah because
guys still want to [ __ ]
and that's why they just go to porn
because then their wife won't give it up
you know
i think it's yeah it's more surprising
when it's like oh she actually likes to
[ __ ] all the time yeah
yeah yeah yeah especially after marriage
like because
because usually you fall in love with
the person they're pretending to be and
then once you're married in all the
matters you're just like
a lot of people anymore a lot of people
just get bigger
my sex drive kind of goes up and down
yeah same yeah depends on how involved i
am in
a work project too like if i'm really
obsessed with what i'm doing with work
like
right now i've been like really obsessed
with putting together my jewelry line
and like just all everything that's
involved with that that i just forget
sometimes about sex
i think you know that passion that
sometimes it goes towards sex
sometimes goes towards projects what
about you gina
it comes and goes like in the beginning
of a relationship like the first year or
so i want sex
all the time and then like i get busy
and i get tired and you know
and so kind of dies down a little bit um
and then
it comes back i mean like like i said
it's just i don't know it depends on how
life is going
yeah yeah and then there are times where
i'm like if i don't have sex for three
days i will [ __ ] rip your head off
yeah but only in a relationship however
when i'm not in a relationship
i am like celibate really i just don't
care for sex
yeah i'm not in a relationship but i'm
not in a relationship
i'm like if i don't get a [ __ ] dick
i'll [ __ ] whoever walks by next because
i just i need it yeah where's like a
relationship you know it's always there
yeah so it's like take that dick for
granted
in a relationship i want to [ __ ] all the
time mostly but outside just me
are we gonna say tiff oh yeah just that
for me it
it's all dependent on how well i'm doing
in my
like how well our relationship is going
and that's
because like when we're good i'm like i
wanna [ __ ] every day all the time
anywhere everywhere but when we're not
and like we don't have that connection
like for me it's really important to
have like for me to get turned on
i need to have that connection and we
need to be like on the same page
and yeah that's normal yeah like i don't
know because like
yeah for me i can't detach sex for it to
just be purely physical and for me to
just want
to have sex just to have sex like i
can't do that i need to have
i need to be turned on like emotionally
first
and have that connection with my partner
in order for me to
want to have sex that makes sense yeah i
can have sex with a stranger just
for sex because then i'll the emotional
need that i have that you're talking
about i'll just project it on to them
and it'll be like a fantasy
yeah whereas like if i'm in a
relationship i i can't do that because i
already know them and i can't project
anything onto them so if we're not doing
well i can't
i can't get ready for sex yeah see i
never had
that like that experience really yeah
you didn't get your whole face because i
only
i've only been in uh since the age of 16
until now i've only been with three guys
yeah and it's i've never had like just
having random sex with a random person
kind of experience
except for like in high school i did
kind of have that but
yeah i don't know it gets complicated
it's different yeah yeah because also
the hormones you know yeah obviously you
want to just [ __ ] but
i guess the older i got it wasn't all
about that so i don't know
um this person assumes one person is the
most likely to pack their bags and move
to new zealand who do you think it is
jess jess okay
why me because i left texas security
college sometimes you know
and you like you're impulsive and not uh
not a bad way not like a random
impulsive but like
you move more than anyone i know like
further than anyone
you move like once a year at least and i
have never
i've been in la for six years i know but
even in la i've lived in
i've never lived less than three years
in a place like i always yeah well there
was reasons why but i think i do enjoy
a new environment so i'm not gonna fight
it but i feel like you know when i first
moved to l.a me and joe were in that
house with like a [ __ ] ton of roommates
and then we got our own place
and then but that was an apartment
downtown and it was loud and [ __ ]
crazy and it was
by skid row so then we got a house in
the suburbs and then and then we broke
up so then i got my own place and then
i wanted something fresher and newer
because i was like dealing with all the
breakup feelings in that place so yeah i
guess i
yeah you change your environment to
change like as your
vibes change yeah and also i did move
1200 miles away from myself
so i'm saying like it's not a bad thing
it's like it's but you're the most
likely to just
go move somewhere around them i feel
like gina would do it too but you just
never actually had she actually did
she went to japan yeah for like four
months that was that was cool most funny
one
yeah i think something like you want it
though like you want to go somewhere
yeah
i turn on for a month um i want to i
would love to
it's just that me being who i am i hate
packing yeah
i was going to say gina seems too lazy
to try to like move somewhere across the
world yeah i'm more likely to just like
leave everything here and let's go order
a pod
it's a storage thing not sponsored you
just [ __ ]
put all your [ __ ] in the pot and then
the fact that she knows that like she's
already excited
about it and that's still too much work
for me like i would rather just leave
everything here and let whoever else
deal with it like it's your problem now
and just start over and buy you can do
that
you don't have anything that expensive
anyway yeah i mean my stupid cat
yeah exactly if i didn't have cats i
would totally live in a tree house in
thailand for like a year
right yeah i finally have a kid if if
tiff was single
and like not a mom she would totally
live in
the most ready to piece out yeah [ __ ]
yeah
like hard yes yeah so i'm only doing it
because i'm the most free and also not
quite that's true
yeah it could be circumstantial yeah
yeah have you ever counted how many
times you've
moved in throughout your lifetime oh no
too many to count probably like a
hundred times
whoa yeah i actually counted once and it
was before a lot of
times that i've moved but i got up to
the number 40.
wow yeah i mean if you think about it
we're like in our 30s
right and if you've moved every year
yeah i moved a lot of times twice and
no that's not true well
um i moved like four times since i've
lived in la and i've lived here for like
14 years
yeah i know i don't i've never stayed in
one place longer than like two years i
don't think
yeah for me it's longer than four yeah
it takes me my last place was the
longest a while to like make it a home
though
so it's like it's hard to leave once i
like make it at home if nothing's ever
home
that's exactly true yeah yeah that's the
reason why i don't put artwork up i'm
like i don't know i'm not gonna be here
see but oh my okay i couldn't live in an
environment where it didn't feel like
home
yeah like it has to i feel safety and
comfort by my home
and and like inspired by my home right
so i need the environment to be very
like stimulating and like aesthetic and
i still decorate i just take it down and
put it somewhere it looks great
that's exactly what i i do too i live in
the temporary like i don't decorate
because it's temporary but you've been
in that house for like a long yeah
yeah [ __ ] five years you haven't hung
up the fact that you could
leave right it's like if like yeah like
i don't feel like something's a home
i'm waiting until i buy my house okay
that's what i'm gonna you know find it
because you're not wasting money
exactly so everything else is temporary
like if i could just have like a
a lawn chair and an inflatable bed yeah
yeah i'm a dude
yeah pretty much i think it's kind of
like um you know when you like think of
a like a
manifesting stuff where like you believe
it first and then you
receive it or whatever like it helps me
in that sense like
why do i have to wait until i have my
dream life why can't i have my dream
life feeling now
like it's like we just got an inflatable
inflatable hotdog like for example
and no we don't have a pool or a regular
hot tub but it feels the same
i don't know it has the same feeling to
it like i and i feel the same amount of
relaxed after
that maybe like eventually i'll have it
but i don't have to
wait to feel that way you know i don't
have to like put that feeling off
right yeah hit us with it jorge uh
somewhere in your heart you regret
becoming a public figure
lots of love somewhere in your heart you
regret becoming a public
oh that's like lots of on my sleeve
that's not somewhere in my heart
that's wide open nope talk about that i
i don't know i just i i do appreciate
the amount of growth i've had
from it because like being subjected to
a whole bunch of people's opinions all
the time does make you reflect on
yourself
but i don't i still don't
love it i don't know and you didn't
because you never it still creates a lot
it still creates a lot of tension in my
head
and with my mental health that i don't
think
that anyone who has my personality type
would really benefit from it besides
like
the friendships i've made or whatever
and then like we had a little bit of
financial success so far but like
overall
if i if i could keep knowing what i know
now and just not have
done it but like understand it and know
the feeling i probably would have just
avoided it
like not done it like if you would have
gone through a simulation yeah if i
could just simulate it feel it and
understand it without having to do all
of it but still keep that lesson
of like what it's really like on this
side i don't think i
would have so i agree with that
assumption
what about you gina no yeah not at all
yeah because
this social media life gave me the life
that i
enjoy and i love so much and have so
much fun you know like
i mean sometimes yeah it gets a little
bit hard and stressful
but that's so rare and i feel like i
find myself
telling myself every week like dude life
is pretty cool same you know like i play
video games i hang out with
you guys i make my own schedule and and
i just
life is fun you know so i don't regret
it at all and i tell people all the time
i can hardly complain like it's fun it's
made my life so exciting and interesting
and i'm thinking
you're on the path that you were about
to be on yeah that's awesome
that's true tiff you're like kind of
like just where you didn't set out to be
yeah public figure ever like what does
that feel like for you
um i relate to actually both of
what jess and gina just said like i'm
more in the middle
but more leaning towards i'm grateful
and the only reason why i lean towards
i'm grateful
more is because of the
i i don't take for granted the effect
that
i have had on others and like how they
reach out to me and tell me like how how
helpful it's been for them to hear my
life experiences and seeing what i've
gone through and
how it could it's just been beneficial
to other people like that's the reason
why
mind tips over heavier to the grateful
side because
i feel like if it wasn't for that and if
it was just purely
for what the experiences i've had the
people i've met and all that stuff like
i don't know if it would feel as
worth it for me to have gone through all
the negative
parts that come with it you know i don't
feel like i've really impacted a lot of
lives or anything probably
like you i mean you've been more in the
public eye than me so you've had more
chance to like have your story out there
people watch your growth and all that
i've been kind of holding back a lot and
like no one
i don't i don't feel like people really
connect with me the way they do with you
so i
i think that's right like i'm not really
getting that extra thing where i'm just
like
okay that was cool but i would just
rather not have
yeah i i definitely think the pros
outweigh the cons i mean there's gonna
be cons with everything that you do
but i don't i don't regret it at all um
you know like i wanted to be an actor
since i was eight years old so
that obviously comes with the territory
but i think like what you said
it's less about i think people put too
much of an emphasis on fame
right now and i don't like that aspect
of it i like the connecting
to people that need to hear it and i
feel like when i
entered acting it was all about story
telling people stories you know like
playing characters that maybe people out
there need to
to relate to that weren't really
represented in film before and
and all the storytelling aspect the art
of it and
um now even with vlogging um i feel like
it's let me get to the most authentic
version of myself
and to be accepted and not only just be
accepted but to have other people being
like thank you for making me feel like
i'm not the only one or like that i'm
i'm not alone like that's exactly the
reason i'm doing this that's exactly it
and it's so like
i didn't feel like i was accepted as a
like growing up
growing um as a kid as a teen even as a
young adult um
i felt like i was constantly wearing a
mask trying to fit in and not even like
a fakeness but just like
trying to people normal yeah like
like blend in you know um that like i
i didn't feel like i could just be me
and have it be accepted like
somewhere down the line someone's gonna
find it annoying or find it like i mean
you are annoying but
i know i'm sure this is never accepted i
love you though
i don't accept it but you know the other
annoying people out there that can
relate
but get all the messages but there's
been like really tough times that i'm
like
man i wish i didn't exist like i wish i
didn't no one knew who i was i wish i
could go hide somewhere and
never and like start a new life all over
again but
in my heart of hearts it's like the
purpose outweighs
the bad like there's a there's a why
thank you all so much for sending in
your assumptions of us
we appreciate you slash hate you just
kidding um
hello you got
um but yeah if you want to we sometimes
do this where we ask you guys for
questions or scenarios breakup scenarios
all kinds of stuff if you would like to
submit something make sure you're
following us on instagram big mood girls
and subscribe to our youtube channel
big mood youtube.com big mood and uh
thank you for listening we love you guys
we'll see you next time